if you look when you're driving these
days you're going to see more and more
electric vehicles and the proliferation
of evs will continue and nv energy has
been a long time proponent of optional
transportation that saves or burns clean
energy and joining us to talk more about
that is marie steele of nb energy
with an expo coming up this saturday
yeah we have a ev ride and drive this
saturday at lorenzo park from 10 to 3.
you're going to have cars like the ones
we have on display right here yes we're
going to have lots of cars to either see
or test drive as well so people can get
their hands on it and test out the
vehicles what do you hear from people
who test drive these vehicles or
purchase them
they love the performance that it's
quiet and they usually actually turn
into folks that go buy vehicles because
they love them yeah it does save money
right now on gas for sure yes i mean i
am an ev driver as well and i do love
driving past the gas station myself
especially when you see 5.50 all over
the place let's talk about the different
cars you have on display here this is an
audi yes this is the audi e-tron it has
about 250 miles of range
and lovely to have you know the suv
support as we look at different models
for for folks as they get to driving one
thing i'm excited about i drive a chevy
bolt which has about 250 mile range but
next year chevy is coming out with a
truck that has a 400 mile range and
that's going to be more and more common
that is going to be more common actually
the mercedes behind us has that range as
well all right the mercedes which i'm
sure is very inexpensive
[Laughter]
yes so you know to that there are a lot
of luxury vehicles that are electric but
we do want to make sure folks know that
there's also you know a used market and
also a price point where it's also
affordable too mustang did we have the
mustang here we don't actually have it
here today but we will have the mustang
maki on saturday for folks to try out
and also the volkswagen id4 you know a
lot more of those models and a ride a
wide range so can anyone come to this
and take a test drive yeah it's a great
event for the family you can show up
we're going to have food trucks we're
going to have recycling of you know of
your phones as well and different things
to learn about evs we want to make sure
people can to look see and feel and for
a certain number of people who show up
early free lunch yes 80 people the first
three to show up we'll have a free lunch
and then but we'll also have the food
truck there for lunch as well it sounds
like a fun fun saturday again where and
when so it's at lorenzi park which is at
washington and rancho on saturday from
10 a.m to 3 p.m and we look forward to
having you out there to learn a little
bit more about it all right marie steele
thanks so much appreciate you being here
let's go to break and we'll be right
back